je pars heureux content et
vous allez dire nourris mais vraiment
très fortement de tous loués pu me
donner de l'émotion dans la voix de joël
regnault lors du conseil municipal
extraordinaire du 15 novembre dernier
maire de la ville depuis 2001 il a
choisi de démissionner avant que la
lassitude ne s'installe selon ses
propres mots une longue ovation a suivi
son discours
émue à ses côtés celle qui devient donc
la nouvelle maire de plaisir joséphine
coleman berger le vote a été sans
surprise seule candidate l'ancienne
adjointe à la culture recueille 30 et
une voix on compte six bulletins blancs
ou nuls il faut que je me fasse
connaître des plaisirs wa parce que les
prix c'est quoi me connaissent en tant
que déléguée à la culture et la
communication mais en tant que maire pas
encore donc je vais faire mon bonhomme
de chemin pour que les jambes
j'espère m'apprécient et comprennent que
je suis dans la même lignée que monsieur
regnault trop d'auto satisfaction
affichée lors de cette soirée pour
l'opposition socialiste emmenée par
bernard ansart
pour lui la campagne des municipales de
mars 2014 a déjà commencé il a
d'ailleurs annoncé sa candidature
nous proposerons donc au plaisir voire
un projet alternatif qui essaiera de
corriger toutes les promesses qui n'ont
pas été tenues nous avons dont nous
aussi un grand sujet financier a traité
puisque
les emprunts qui ont été renégociés en
2008 met la ville quand même dans une
difficulté que nous aurons
vraisemblablement à gérer dans les 25
prochaines années en artsakh a déclaré
sa candidature ce soir alors est-ce que
c'était le moment opportun je ne sais
pas en tout cas il la choisit donc on
sait maintenant au moins dans connu au
moins maintenant de deux des candidats
de 2014 et
on verra ce que nous centristes nous
ferons pas seulement là joël regnault
siège dorénavant tant qu'adjoint il a
annoncé qu'il ne serait pas présent sur
la liste de l'ump ni sur aucune autre en